john paul de gea is the billionaire
founder of the paul mitchell line
and the patron spirits company with a
net worth of over 3
billion he went from selling flowers and
newspapers to support his family at age
9 and being told by his teacher that he
would never succeed at anything
in life to becoming a self-made
billionaire and philanthropist
need motivation watch top 10 with
believe nation
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
john paul de jouria and my take on his
top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be prepared for rejection
one of the great secrets in life to
becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early twenties
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection
because if you're prepared for a lot of
rejection it comes you don't get turned
off you don't get disappointed like well
i'm not going to do this anymore no one
thinks it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars
they slam them in your face you must be
just as enthusiastic
on door number 101 as door number one
and that's what the real secrets and
growing up as kids in downtown l.a
we all knew that we didn't have a lot we
noticed a lot of things going to turn
you down
at seven trying to sell a flower pot on
the street most people said no but it's
only 50 cents no no no
sooner a waitress and a little
restaurant said
only 50 cents that's really great she
bought it from us
and we went built another one rule
number two stay positive
if you take a look at life you can have
your glasses they say half empty or half
full is how you look at it
now i've been homeless twice when you
are down
first time was 22 years old and i had a
child
homeless with a kid you know he was a
couple years old which would be
interesting because most people see you
now in this multi-billion dollar
situation
they would never believe that at 22 you
were homeless with a kid
i mean it didn't look like the
trajectory was heading here right yeah
but when you're down and out and you're
that far down and you've got a kid
and you're kicked out of your place
because rents do you don't have the
money and your wife took off with
everything
everything everything yeah just little
kids wow anyways we were just too young
to get married uh
so you know how to make it now when
you're that low found a friend of mine
who's a blue singer said
when you get down so low and you look up
all you could see is an edge right
when you're that low you could only go
up true so instead of you have a choice
you could sit around and blame what
happened to you on
everybody else which is usually what
people do
or say hey that's how things turned out
now i'm going to turn things around
rule number three be in the reorder
business
i'd love to share this with everybody
don't ever go into the selling business
whether you have the greatest service in
the world or the greatest product
never go in there to sell your product
go in there to be in the
reorder business that's kind of your
mentality that's true
yeah because if you're going to sell it
that's where your focus is if you want
to be in the reorder business
even if it's a one-time product whatever
you do is so good
that they'll want to tell somebody else
or reorder themselves
rule number four go after opportunities
if you had to define the american dream
what would you say
it is that when you think
that there's all the opportunity you
want and you don't know any better
you go after it in my generation it was
a pleasure work
whether it was at the variety boys club
at seven years old making flower pots
going on selling them or
christmas cards at nine or uh going on
the streets at
11 years old delivering morning
newspapers
for us it was fun to work now what do we
do with the money we gave to my mom so
we have a better way of life
we got into high school my brother and i
saved a little bit of it for our car
which happened to be a junker but we
rebuilt it in auto shop
but because we for us it was a pleasure
to work you know just because wow we got
a job it was so cool
also if you want to learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
it's free
the link to join is in the description
below there's my
two and a half year old son sitting on
the floor in a bunch of clothes and
there's a note
can't handle it anymore better off with
you good luck
i'm gone rule number five think with
your heart
many times i've gone with what i thought
was fact and sometimes
i thought we're pretty good hunches and
i didn't do so well
but i'm very fortunate that more than 50
of the time
i did do very very well and i'm finding
out more recently in my life the last
couple years
that you try not to just think with your
brain but think with your heart
how do you feel about the situation how
do you feel about the people
no matter how kind they are and i've had
some really nice people
got in foreign countries and everything
else that were the nicest people in the
world
turned out to be total rip-offs but i
didn't know that
there were clues along the way so i say
to everybody and i say to myself now
feel the person out or feel the
situation with your heart what is your
instinct
i think now more in life that i go off
instinct plus facts you obviously have
to have some facts along with it does it
become easier the more you do it
yep much easier when you're when you're
set to
well how do i feel about this shall we
say with data
stable data that i have how do i feel
about these facts and then and how i
feel about it
just my intuition how do i feel about it
from my heart yeah and the more you
think about doing it that way the more
it happens
rule number six take responsibility when
you're down and out
first thing people do is blame it on
everybody else but themselves so true
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook
you also have the responsibility of
turning things around when i started
paul mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident and i i started the
company out of the back seat of my car
how old were you at that time 37
that was 34 35 at that time so you're
homeless at 34 35 again yeah
and what was this series of events that
led to that second time it was just that
we had money set up a half a million
bucks
we need to start the company with that
kind of money and uh the day i
was ready to start go down the bank and
get the money my partner the hairdresser
paul mitchell
flew her from hawaii with his girlfriend
and uh we were ready to get the money
and get
going and get started i'd left
everything i did
my relationship wasn't working out so
left the house plenty of money for many
months with her
had a few hundred bucks in my pocket
took the used car which is 20 years old
but a decent one okay down the hill to
get the money
wow i was going to check into an
efficiency and all set up
the money never came in no way nev the
guy
changed his mind 1980 81
inflation in the united states is 12 and
a half percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate 17 percent
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and
interest uh and unemployment was 10. the
united states the guy said
you're his hostages are still in iran
which they were at that time
he says is this a terrible i'm sorry
it's the last minute no
so it's a matter of what are we going to
do rule number seven
value your time what is your
decision-making process
or thinking when it comes to investing
your time your money your energy
sure it's very important because time is
the most valuable thing you have
is one make sure where you're putting
your time and energy
is something you want to do not just
because you're exploring with people you
don't like or a business you don't like
or a situation you don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you could do something with
to do something great not just make
money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone
just to make money then it means you've
already decided to take a portion of
your time to make these papers that are
backed up by nothing but will buy stuff
to call it a possession we have all
these great possessions
well if you have these great possessions
could you give them away
if you had any possession you could give
it away hey great it was a possession
and you moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
rule number eight learn from experience
how did you
get through like tactically to a sale
in the encyclopedia world like people
don't want to hear from you
so like how do you overcome that what a
question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days i was at it for three
and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview
they told you all you could possibly
make off commission only and we were in
training for three days it was a
presentation that was scripted
we'd have to memorize the whole thing
well when you got in the field you
remember parts of it
you knock on doors you're not quite sure
of yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face
but what happens after a while you start
getting used to it
and you see what you can say or do
that'll make it better
but when you go back the next day with
your other sales people what you see
what you do what did i say
so let's say knock on 100 door skin into
one give 10 presentations to sell one
book
but then when you get better and better
at it through your experiences and
losses along the way
it sharpens you up where all of a sudden
i got to a point where
if i gave three presentations i have no
less than one order
commission only but i believe that i
could do that i believe that
colleges were the best set of books
because a high school student could read
it it wasn't like a college manual you
had to read
and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe
that what you're doing is good is going
to benefit somebody and you learn as you
go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people know these things look
someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye
because you feel uncomfortable of course
you do they're not on the same
wavelength you're under the same
frequency so what do you do how do you
overcome that
you learn these things along the way you
look them right between the eyes or
their eyebrows looks like you're looking
over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh
there's all these things and of course
smile smile is the most wonderful thing
god gave us
and you don't smile when you first talk
to somebody you smile before you knock
on their door
and if your day sucks you fake it hi how
you doing so when you smile everything
changes
people change rule number nine believe
at what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for
what was the point where you guys said
hmm like let's do this like what was the
well we were planning to do it because i
knew the business
i was in marketing sales and structure
and had connections with
uh product development and i didn't do
hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world very advanced in what
he did
however he didn't do business it was the
perfect combination
these two guys together we're just the
best of friends and we knew we could do
it uh
obviously we started out with nothing we
made the decision let's just let's just
make
this happen and as you will see in your
guests we'll see when they look at good
fortune the movie
and it's on itunes it's on amazon all
those when they
look at it it's a whole story of
starting in america
with nothing a couple times and making
things happen because of what you
believe in
but the important thing is even we had
nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first coming to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state
wow or other things we did why not shake
your hand today sure you betcha but i
applaud you
that's awesome it's still going on that
one and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is share your feelings i have had before
co-partners in some businesses i've
tried and
not as good as my partner paul mitchell
but in other businesses and they didn't
turn out to be what i thought they would
be
so if you have a partner one you've got
to be friendly to one another
you also have to have your boundaries
where okay i live my life you live your
life we can't live it all together we're
together
we have a certain goal now if you do
have i call it a challenge opposed to a
problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively
don't attack on it instead it's much
easier to say
well you know liz uh you're you're a
wonderful person we've done some really
great business together
but with all due respect when i came in
here i had a great idea wanted to tell
you
and you kept on cutting me off and it
made me feel bad liz you know as well
that just made me feel bad and i know
you're like to hear it i just wanted to
share that with you
you share your feelings with the person
if they have an idea you don't think
it's any good you could say you know
that's
that that's a great idea i could
appreciate where you're coming from
always validate the person
however can we look at this a little
differently maybe we can enhance it and
build upon it
and you come in with your two cents
always respect the other person
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan and when you share your plan
and have public accountability
it raises your chances of following
through even higher
so that's what i want to do today for
you guys you watch this video
what was your single biggest takeaway
and what is your plan
to take action on it this week let me
know put it down in the comments below
what are your core values personally and
professionally uh core values are
i would say it's the golden rule do unto
others
as you would have others do unto you
that's the basis for most religions but
they get sometimes carried away in
rights and rituals
but that's the core value do unto others
as you'd have others do unto you
and then it's the feeling of knowing
that success
unshared is definitely failure in other
words when you make it
it's not really just about yourself
making it hey if you make it you know
you made it
but along the way one of the great
lessons to learn
is it's not all about you it's about
your ability to be of service to this
planet while you're here
and by saying me me me me look what i
did this is me
hey here's my building my name's on it
you know i did this you didn't
by doing something like that it kind of
takes away
from how genuine you are and because
people don't like to just listen to
people talk about themselves how great
they are they want to know incorporate
it to make them successful also or do
something a little different and i think
that's very very important
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there